out there questions what's what's the
most dangerous animal
in the Amazon would you say
mammal let's go with mammal dangerous
mammal like dangerous in terms of you
walking around doing the solo hike I'm
gonna disappoint everybody with this but
it's it's it's humans it's nothing
there's no if I'm out in the Amazon
there's nothing that's going to attack
me
you know and in India you might have you
might have an old leopard or a tiger
that's missing a tooth that decides your
prey or you might have an angry elephant
that's a must that just decides to just
decides to flatten you in the Amazon
you're not this real jaguars won't even
let you see them yeah and there's really
nothing else one of my friends uh
brilliant scientist friend of mine Pat
got attacked by a rabid ocelot once but
that's like a diesel house cat just
having a fit you know that's it wasn't
the worst thing in the world
it's just the yeah whole
Kingdom okay what uh in terms of humans
you said
um that the tribes some of them
uncontacted yeah can be exceptionally
dangerous what's your experience with
them what should people learn because
it's such a fascinating part
of life here on Earth that there's
tribes that don't have much or any
contact with the quote-unquote Civilized
world
most of the people that I meet don't
actually really understand how
how isolated these people are or how
weird it is that we're sitting here and
that we have iPhones and airplanes and
all this stuff and these people are
living naked in the forest at this
moment
and so
the the the thing though you know I also
was recently somebody somebody said oh
this like Paleolithic tribes and it's
like no no just by default they're
modern tribes living now
they just happen to be living out in the
jungle and there's a huge debate about
you know do we try and contact them and
bring them in
and there's two camps of people on this
who they said it was it was it was the
trauma of the rubber boom that sent them
out that far into the forest and made
them terrified of the outside world
and so that's also what made them so
hyper violent I mean they're they're I
there's one of the guys we work with on
our team Victor was in I think it was
2004. he's coming down river and he had
a load of mahogany wood and he's
piloting this boat
and
he sent two people a husband and wife
ahead to go start cooking breakfast on
the beach so they could put the little
kitchenette thing down and pick put the
propane he sent them ahead as the he's
going nice and slow at the barge coming
down the river they go ahead reach the
beach they get out he starts cutting
some cane to start making a fire
tribe comes out no warning they just
start screaming they start shooting
arrows the man instantly gets an arrow
through the leg and it pins his leg so
he can't run he tells his wife go save
yourself and she does she jumps in the
water this arrow is falling around her
too and as she's floating down the river
she looks back and the last thing she
sees is these guys getting to her
husband and beginning to rip him apart
as Victor comes down the river this is a
guy we work with every day he comes down
the river and sees his friend
disemboweled opened up dissected his
parts are all over the beach the beach
is red and they only found out what
happened because they found her later on
holding on to a stick in the river and
they're like what happened and she was
like they just attacked they don't want
people on their land on the on the on
the the sort of the underground WhatsApp
chain of the Amazon they a few in August
like this was not an internationally
known
um some loggers went up and tried to
steal a few trees from where the tribes
were and then everybody sent the
pictures of what the loggers looked like
after a few days because the tribes
porcupine them with arrows they were
laying there on the ground with just
arrows sticking out of their bodies and
then eventually the authorities came out
and looked and there was just these
white
but I'll show you the pictures later
there's these white puffy bodies with
like the skulls sticking out and it was
like you don't mess with these tribes I
wonder what are the what's the mythology
around that they construct around who
these Outsiders are are they gods are
they demons are they humans
who are they who are we to them well you
got to go back to the rubber Boom the
the rubber Barons went down there and at
the start of the Industrial Revolution
the only way to get rubber
was to mine it from the trees that were
out in the forest and so the only way to
do that because you can't make a rubber
Plantation in the jungle the the rubber
when it's in Plantation form when it's a
monoculture it gets this Leaf blight and
it all dies Henry Ford tried it didn't
work and so what they did was they sent
these people down who just whipped
burned enslaved raped and pillaged the
people it's one of the worst periods in
human suffering that I've ever read
about
um one missionary said they were killing
the locals the way you or I would kill a
mosquito they just went nuts and so they
sent them out and they would come back
with rubber and this would go to fuel
the Industrial Revolution for hoses and
gaskets and tires and all this stuff
that suddenly we needed
um and it was during that time that
these these these you know gangs of
foreigners would go into the jungle to
enslave the natives
that these uncontacted tribes went back
into the jungle and said not us
and they have six foot bows and seven
foot Arrows with bamboo tips they make
the bamboo tips into razor blades
and so when those things fly actually
one of my Rangers one of the Jungle
Keepers team
um was present when the tribes had come
out onto the river and he tried to help
them because they're nomadic and they
live out there and so there's an element
of like
brother like you know they're trying to
be like you don't need to be like this
like we're friendly so they sent a canoe
across the river with bananas and so
he's up to his waist in the river and
the tribes are right across the river
and and
this shot and he sees the Arrow coming
right at his head and as he moved to the
side it hit him at the temple and sliced
him back towards the ear opening him to
the skull
he's fine but let me tell you something
when he goes and gets a crew cut it's
the most badass the scar you've ever
seen man and so he he always keeps it
real short on that side but but even if
we try to help them that they're not
necessarily friend tough I said tough
lesson
yeah
I suppose they have a point they have a
point and and protecting them is is a
default of you know now that we're
protecting all this ecosystems and all
these other indigenous communities it's
like we all sort of live with this
knowledge that they're the Hermanos the
brothers are out there and that's the
way they want to keep it and so we just
have to be respectful of like you don't
camp on certain beaches at certain times
of the year because we know that they
might be there you really have to be
careful about that have you yourself
interacted with any my interaction with
them came on a solo where I pushed it a
little bit too far
and I I was planning to do a three week
this was like the big one and I I got
dropped off by poachers up a river and I
I went past the point where they were
like names there I said what what what
tributary are we on and they were like
tributary and I was like okay
and I said leave me here and I remember
the guy being like are you committing
suicide and he didn't understand that I
was like no I have a backpack and I have
like food and like I'm gonna like take
videos and have a tripod and I was like
we're cool here and they looked at me
like they were like goodbye and I was
like all right and I went up this River
and
and again like you just you learn these
things like you know it was only when
I'd been alone for a week that you
realize you're you know is that saying
that like oh you're you're born alone
and you die alone it's like no you're
not you're born into a room full of
people usually at the very least your
mother's there for everybody and uh and
so you've been around people probably if
you're a normal person every single day
of your life you've seen dozens if not
hundreds of people
and all of a sudden you realize what a
social creature we are
because on day six it gets weird for me
it got weird I know there's people that
can do it longer so what is it what does
that mean like longing for contact like
are you lonely longing for contact the
Distortion of reality in the sense that
like you know you wake up and there's no
one there and you start to
you know you're going up a river so I
would I would keep I kept looking back
down river and
almost thinking of my life as something
it was almost like I had already died
and I had gone to somewhere else and I
was looking back on that life as like
something that I had experienced And
Then There came this Panic of what if
it's gone or like what if World War III
broke out and I just don't know about it
my family in New York is vaporizing
something just you just you you're
you're actually your ability to
comprehend and interpret reality kind of
requires other people it's not just that
you're lonely you need that contact
actually just perceive the world make
sense of it all of that so you start
basically hallucinating I have a certain
kind of way I started feeling very
uncomfortable
um and it doesn't help also that like
Santiago told me these stories where
he's like if you hear capuchins sounding
not quite monkeys if you hear capuchin
monkey sounding not quite like capuchins
he goes it's the tribe and they're
coming to get you
and then so um the guy who was shot
Ignacio they showed me videos where we
saw them on the beach and they're
communicating in Monkey calls they're
using it as code so that we don't
understand them even though we don't
speak their language but they're they're
using animal calls and so every night
you go to sleep and then you go
did that cinema sound off and you're
like you know and it's really hard
to fall asleep and then like one night I
I messed up and I left a fish I like
cleaned this fish I ate like this huge
fish I just ate it to my face you're
putting out like Marathon levels of of
energy every day like you know Goggins
would love solos this is awesome yeah
you eat the fish Raw uh this one I
actually cooked it but you know the
skeleton was laying there right right
outside my tent stupid yeah and in the
middle of the night I wake up and I just
could tell there was something there you
know and then like you almost don't want
to look it's like when you're a kid at
the basement door and you're like is
there a ghost it's like I like unzip the
tent and I like open it up and there's
like 27 black cayman outside of my tent
all looking at me like this and like
some of their heads are this big and
they're like there's fish there can we
have it and I'm like holy and like
you know I was like do I I kind of like
had to like scooch the tent back and
like move back and let them have their
fish and there's a host of crocodiles
outside of my tent yeah
um but no so then there's three how many
like 27 maybe there's a lot and big ones
small ones medium sized one every type
thing we're all there and their eyes
glow in the night you know you shine a
light at animals and they haven't taping
them lucidum and so their their eye
shine comes back at you if you shine a
headlamp at a at a jaguar or a frog or
almost every animal has a tape in them
so he's a Croc there's a whole lot of
them yeah I thought can we go back to
the part of the conversation where you
said the jungle is not dangerous the
humans are the most dangerous did they
eat me no why didn't they eat you they
wanted the fish is there some way of you
interacting with them that shows that
you're not social harm
I don't believe so I'm sure there's
someone out there that thinks they can
talk to Crocs but because there's a
there's a story of you grabbing a Croc
by the tail yes what did you learn from
that learn to not always listen to JJ so
JJ was testing you to uh yeah to see how
stupid it was how do you hold the
crocodile exactly you have to get them
by the head like an anaconda like this
and so so you're one of the world actors
to grabbing creatures by the head I
wouldn't say World expert but I've done
a lot of it um I also have you see that
there's like kind of a ball there that's
where a crocodile tooth went in that
side and like came out that side of my
house that was a really good Chomp and
the watch I was wearing at the time
saved me because that like that
um real fast just Chomp just whack like
somebody took a sledgehammer you put
your hand on the table and I just went
really hurt
um shouldn't have been doing that what
how did that come up because I caught a
crock that was too big so usually when
we catch little Caiman in the streams
and we measure them to monitor the
populations
um you get it by the neck and then I
tuck the tail under my arm and I hold it
and you're talking about a little you
know four foot Croc nothing and I I this
one I dove into a into a swamp and I
caught like a six foot
spectacle Cayman and her head was big
and I had her by the neck and I realized
I couldn't get her tail under my arm
because her tail was all the way back
there and she started thrashing
and it was like probably Croc number 375
that I'd caught and I just got a little
cocky and I said ah just you know I just
I just like grabbed her by a leg I was
like I got this and she just came back
and tagged me and I went okay gonna go
back to being safe just to linger on it
what uh
is it one of the one of the bigger
predators in the Amazon what and it's is
it going to uh are they going extinct
black caimans black caiman were I
believe they were critically endangered
for a while because for a while the
fashion industry loved their skin it's
soft and it's black
um they're bouncing back a little bit
now you know like most animals if you
leave them alone they'll be fine I mean
Crocs have been through you know how
many millions and millions of years on
Earth before us I mean that's even the
joke with with the joke but that's the
Grim reality of tiger conservation it's
there was a hundred thousand Tigers in
1900.
now this 4 000 Tigers left on Earth
it's not rocket science all you have to
do is not bulldoze their forest and
allow there to be some deer and tigers
will be fine that's it it's so simple
and that's like sometimes where I feel
like I have the dumbest job in the world
I'm like guys please stop killing the
things that Keep Us Alive
the Amazon regulates our Global Climate
produces medicine is home to indigenous
people it's beautiful
rainforests only cover three percent of
the planet's land mass like it's not
that much to ask
if you uh leave their home untouched
they'll figure out how to have sex and
multiply except for pandas apparently
because pandas you have to convince yeah
uh humpbacks humpbacks they went down to
they went from 130 000 down to I think
about 8 000.
at whaling times and then when we banned
whaling since that time where I think
we're back up to over a hundred thousand
humpback whales they've bounced back
it's a success story we're not going to
lose them
okay so you're in this on a solo
with uh Crocs looking at you see this is
why you're good at this you know I I
would have lost we would have been no
that's pretty ever with the fish that
was your mistake that was my mistake I
don't understand how you're still alive
I mean I
it's really inspiring when you come
we're gonna I'm gonna show you
yeah you told me you're coming around
you're 100 coming yeah but you know
if there's any place I mean
um
a sort of a grim joke but if there's any
way to die uh that's a good one if I'm
being honest it's a cool one it's a
pretty cool one it'll become part of the
party yeah yeah I mean there's it's I'm
not even like joking there's a there's a
Oneness to the whole thing
ever all the stories just reading your
work looking at your work I
it seems like you are part of this
machine that is nature the this this
incredible
machine like we all die
and we're all part of this big thing
that humans do have the capability to
also construct narratives and stories
and myths and tell them to each other
and share them with each other and have
more sophisticated ways therefore to
communicate love to each other but
animals do as well they communicate love
maybe more simply
maybe more honestly
anyway so you're you with the Crocs and
the fish
yeah so I messed up I left the fish out
Croc showed up outside my tent but in
the end it was fine I I backed off they
had their way with the fish and then
they all started biting each other it
was fun to watch is it a general story
to interrupt is that a general rule you
want to not leave
yeah just like if you're camping in the
Northeast you don't leave like you do a
bear bag or a bear canister you don't
you don't want to invite the wild
animals I really did mess up I kind of
was just like you know whatever I do
this every now and then I get a little
too Cavalier
um and that the ocean is almost almost
taken me down for that a few times
um but yeah so the Crocs and then you
keep going for a few days and my plan
was to get to a point
where I reached the end of the tributary
and this had a very
um
you know again for me this is like a
pilgrimage
this is like this is like me going into
the heart of the the very center and
soul and essence of everything that I am
fascinated with like as close to God as
you can get because you're leaving every
type of security every human
relationship you're also pushing all
your chips in
and so it's it's
I you know the every step I took further
up River it got weirder and weirder and
more intense and every day and every
moment it changed and I was I brought
pictures at the time there's no way to
keep a phone charged I didn't have like
a power bank or anything
um you know I brought pictures from home
I brought a I brought a National
Geographic magazine
um something just to you know
and um
there came a day right when I was
getting to the end like to the point
where the river was so shallow that it
was just a trickle and I was walking on
the rocks and the Andes mountains were
in front of me and I was like reaching
the the place and the music was swelling
and then
all of a sudden I saw smoke around the
next Bend
and I I like my spine is reacting right
now as I talk about it because I I knew
I knew what I was going to see because I
knew that it was impossible for loggers
to be out there there's no motor that
could take you the boat would have run
aground miles ago and so I I went
and this is the other this is the other
idiot thing it's like just turn around
yeah just do it I'm that kid though when
you see like a wet paint sign like I
walk by and I touch the wall yep and uh
so I I I went around the bend
and and I see I see a few naked people
on the beach
and they see me
and we're like a good distance apart
it's there on the other side of the
river
but you know arrow in hand bow in hand
the the intention of pose they're
looking at me they're clearly conversing
and that moment lasted for a a long
moment where I said
this is the part of the story where they
are going to
rip me apart dissect me to see what I
eat I mean every other story in the
region that we've heard
that's the ending of it if you're alone
with these people it's not going to go
well and I have nothing to defend myself
with
um and I just I turned and I ran for
like three hours and I got in the river
and I swam for a while and all my food
got wet
um I mean everything I just you know all
right just ran for dear life and and my
my get out plan the thing after I
crossed the mountains and came down into
the next tributary was I had a pack raft
that's a tiny little inflatable raft
good enough to handle Rapids and I
inflated the pack raft once the once the
river was like six inches deep I
inflated the pack raft and I went and I
went for the rest of that day into the
night I went into the point that my
headlamp died and I was just floating
floating in a raft down the Amazon and
hitting into things and I was like okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna pop this raft so it
got out of the raft to set up my tent
and I was like I need some sleep I was
freaking out I hadn't had food and now
you know hours and hours and hours
as soon as I fell asleep
my brain comes up with the dream
of that I hear voices they're right
outside the tent I just you know
sleeping was worse than being awake so I
woke up got back in the tent and then at
one point it was really cool because one
of those one of the same black cayman
that had come for the the fish as I'm
going down river he came right up next
to me and the two of us were going and
he was just like motoring down river
this giant like 16 foot crocodile he
just like came up to me and like looked
at me as I was going and it was funny
because I wasn't scared of him I was
scared of them
and yeah it took me like a week to get
back to town and and again the things
you learn in these moments the the you
know the appreciation for your parents
the the the the what a hug feels like
you know when you when you are are faced
with
pretty much certainty that you're not
gonna get those things again
whether it's from MRSA or uncontacted
tribes or you know
um I find that that it brings it brings
it brings you this new joy for life
where you just being that close to death
yeah you go yeah you go my God this is
all a miracle
it's sad because they're human just like
you
actually how different are they like if
you were forced
to interact for a week together where
they can't they're not allowed to kill
you
like not allowed to kill me would they
are they how fundamentally different are
they do you think I don't think I don't
think they're different I think they're
like any other Amazonian natives um
they're they're tall they seem to have
tall genetics
um and there's places you know again
there's there's what is known and then
there's what we know down there like
there's there's one Community where I
don't know whether it was like a bad
rainstorm or something but some kid from
the uncontacted tribes did end up in a
village and so we he learned
Spanish or he learned whatever dialect
they speak in that Village and so he's
told us a little bit about what life was
like with them but like
they're just people
they're just people they have their own
culture they know about medicines that
we don't know about they definitely have
hunting practices that that we don't
understand they can hit a spider monkey
out of a 160 foot tree with a bamboo
Arrow
we can't do that
I mean they are incredible hunters and
also like living naked in the jungle
with the bot flies and the mosquitoes
I don't know how they do it like
sometimes at night and again we don't
have night vision whereas almost every
other animal does
and sometimes we'll be sitting you know
on our you know at the research station
at night and we'll be just drinking and
like looking out and at the you know
we'll scare each other we'll go you know
we realize if they were out there right
now they could be looking at us and it's
like the truth is is that when it's dark
out there
they can't see
it's not easy to start a fire with
matches and a lighter and gasoline they
do it with friction
they have some some beads on Survival
that we could really learn from
um
not to mention that then you have people
that believe that they are actually the
Guardians of the extinct giant ground
sloth and what they're doing is you know
living out there because they're
protecting a secret population of
previously extinct megafauna but there's
all kinds I mean this it's like you you
go into the crypto world so quick I've
heard so many people be like
but then again you have to be humble at
how little we know about
about that world about the world of life
like you said there's so much of life in
the Amazon that we don't uh creatures
with no names